it was an election supposed to bring
peace but brought fear fume aliens came
out to vote because of the threat of a
bomb attack at polling stations for
catching the corona virus one of the
voters said it was a risk worth taking
compound part of the affair when we talk
of peace we need a functioning assembly
that can make decisions and take action
so that our country can move forward
under 2015 peace agreement signed with
armed groups in northern Mali the
government agreed to a parliamentary
election and to change the constitution
to give more autonomy to regions the
election was canceled twice because of
insecurity vowing to overthrow the
government our fighters linked to the is
GS in al-qaeda they called for a boycott
of the elections after the kidnapping of
opposition leader suma LSC say three
weeks ago for first time parliamentary
candidate Hamad in dqo dialogue not
military operations is the solution
in combat since we are incapable of
fighting them we should negotiate with
them even if we have to apply Sharia it
shouldn't be a problem
95% of us are Muslims why fear in
Islamic Republic armed groups are
pitting ethnic groups against each other
such as the Fulani and Dogon villagers
fight each other in central Mali but
after being forced from their homes by
repeated attacks they live in peace side
by side in this makeshift camp in Bamako
Janet a lot went till when I've been
open in normal circumstances I would
have taken part in the vote but we can't
have them here I would have liked to
have had my voice in this election while
several polling stations were attacked
by armed groups the government announced
several new coronavirus infections and
that hundreds that were in treatment
with most candidates failing to get an
outright majority in the first round two
weeks ago the turnout was low in the
second round
the ruling party rally for Mali is set
to win the majority of the votes the
legitimacy of the results is already
being questioned by the opposition and
all of those that stayed at home during
the vote nicholas hawk al jazeera